defense secretary do we have when we
look at this sort of operation do we
have a kill list for instance and is
someone like jihadi John top of that
well really it's the other way round
they have a kill list these terrorists
have a list of targets in this country
events that they want to attack they're
the ones who are trying to attack us I'm
not going to go into details I'm afraid
of who else obviously is is being
watched at the moment but there are a
number of terrorists out there and we
can't of coral out further action like
this we will take this action where it's
absolutely necessary where there is no
other alternative way of preventing the
armed attack and when we've done that
then we'll come to Parliament as the
Prime Minister did yesterday and explain
the circumstances final question to you
what message do you hope or does this
send I to Isis I hope it sends a very
clear message to Isis though we won't
tolerate people planning attacks on our
streets planning to attack Britain we've
had 31 of our citizens murdered on a
beach in Tunisia where we're not
prepared to tolerate that and if we have
the necessary information if we find out
who is planning and directing these
attacks then we're going to do something
about it and if there's no other way of
preventing these attacks then we will
use all the military might at our
disposal to deal with them add source
which is at the ISIL headquarters in
Syria